hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ihr seht schon dass ich heute
überraschender weise man ein video im
sitzen aufnehme das sind ganz einfach
daran weil ich das stehen verlernt habe
spaß beiseite freunde den letzten tagen
waren köln die komplette karneval
eskalation am laufen und ihr hört das
glaube ich auch schon an meiner stimme
allerdings darf ich euch heute am
dienstag dennoch sehr herzlich begrüßen
wir freuen uns einer neuen episode take
you stay und ich würde sagen wir starten
wieder mit dem besten tik tok der woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja lasst mal jetzt ein daumen hoch unter
dem video daher wenn es auch bei euch
geklappt hat da hat mir nun allerdings
mit dem richtigen erster tik tok für die
heutige episode tik tok tuesday und zwar
erklärt uns eine person wofür man in
einem supermarkt einkaufswagen diese
komischen kleinen löcher im wagen
benutzt
danke werde ich dann beim nächsten
supermarkt besuch auf jeden fall
dann werde ich das sprachenlernen of
life des jupa die youtube hinweg
ok
hallo
dass die dummen
[Musik]
nico vokale war dabei auch noch mal ganz
kurz und zwar hatte ich ja am freitag
geburtstag
ja danke danke schön finden für den
applaus ich wollte mich nur ganz kurz
noch mal persönlich für eure
zehntausenden kommentare und instagram
die ems und allgemein glückwünsche
bedanken auch leute die mich an karneval
hier in köln getroffen haben und auch an
meinem geburtstag ist er dieses kissen
luca job gelaunt obwohl ich mich auch
bedanken dass das kitzeln haben das 1000
mal produziert das waren 4 minuten
ausverkauft und ich hab mir sind die
tränen gekommen
also wirklich das ist ein riesiger
support und ich habe mich so gefreut
aber alle glückwünsche wollte nur ganz
kurz sagen aber jetzt machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten video
ich liebe tik tok tuesday
aber irgendwie hat sich auch beim finish
rollstuhl-basketball break
[Musik]
wie kommt man auf so aus als sei ich
will es nicht sagen ich will dich sagen
es ist die wahrheit
jetzt haben wir die alte dame hier
wieder die hat mir auch schon in der
letzten folge tik tok you stay wo sie
den ganzen leuten die das auf ticket
gemacht haben das experiment mit einer
cola und dort mensch aus reingeschmissen
dann ist montiert dass er irgendwie ganz
kohlensäure raus das hat sich nicht
geglaubt und hat deshalb nach gemacht
und wurde komplett nass und jetzt will
sie es mit pepsi anscheinend
ausprobieren wir schauen wir ob das
jetzt auch nach hinten los geht's
[Musik]
ja ja es ist entspannt videos im sitzen
auf zudem da muss ich gar nicht durch
mein zimmer klatschen laufen ich werde
jetzt meine freundin projekten ist
eingefangen hätte ich keine habe
[Musik]
das ist schaue ich mir hier
ich weiß nicht ob mein humor wirklich so
am arsch ist dass ich so was so witzig
finde aber schreibt mir doch mal gerne
favorit und machen wir nun allerdings
weiter mit einem tick tock video bei dem
mann gefragt was man versteht man hört
nämlich einen sound und soll dann
kommentieren was man versteht also
schaut euch jetzt das video hier an und
schreibt mir währenddessen mal und in
die kommentare was ihr versteht
[Gelächter]
ich
denn als er ich habe immer das
verstanden worauf ich gerade geschaut
habe
[Musik]
denn ja es ist ein glück also weg mit
mir
[Musik]
ich bin irgendwie krank aber irgendwie
auch nicht das ist ein thema
[Musik]
das traurige ist das ganze tier war
immer noch lila als alle prank profi
videos hat sich das nächste video auf
meiner homepage vorgeschlagen und mir
die ersten sekunden angeschaut habe habe
ich mir im ersten moment gedacht hey da
will eine person irgendwie lustig sein
aber das ist eigentlich was worüber man
nicht lachen sollte dann habe ich
allerdings das video wirklich bis zum
ende geschaut habe mir wirklich gedacht
und rottweil das ist wirklich so
passiert
schaut schaut einfach selbst
[Musik]
also ich hoffe dir geht es gut und ich
finde es hammer dass du das machst in
der jugendpsychiatrie und
gute besserung
[Musik]
bruder 1 und 2 ihr seid für mich am
arsch
o
hat jemand gesagt das ist die wahrheit
genau die gleiche person hatten wir auch
schon in der letzten folge tik tok user
und dass er auch weggerutscht
es ist ein kanal konzept er zerstört
essen und fliegt danach auf die fresse
typisch menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend kommen wir nur noch schon zum
vorletzten tik tok video für die heutige
episode tecdoc tuesday und zwar richtet
sich dieses wieder an alle personen die
noch nie einen schallt wagen gefahren
sind
ich denke einige von euch machen gerade
ihren führerschein also bleibt auf jeden
fall dran schaut euch das jetzt hier
komplett an und ihr werdet den trip ihr
werdet einen trip haben danach ihr
werdet den ticker ihr werdet den trick
des jahrtausends er verbaut ich sagen
meine fresse dort kommentiert dass man
in der luft erst an zweiter gang hoch in
die mitte nach oben dritten so wie es da
steht dann geht in den pott montag ihren
fünften titel nach oben von dem vierten
aus rechts hoch dann in den sechsten so
wenn ich dann so circa bei 180 190 seid
geht ihr dann auf für richtig schnell
bestehen zu 99 prozent daraus dass ich
mir in facebook gebe oder klatsche und
an der stelle würde ich jetzt auch die
heutige episode tik tok tuesday beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann das gern einen daumen
hoch unter dem video her da wie bereits
zu beginn oder zum mitte oder irgendwann
in diesem video gesagt schreibt mir die
kommentare was ihr bei diesem video hier
gehört habt sollen helfen wollen sollen
aber und jetzt zu leben gern meinen
kanal unter dem video wenn ihr noch kein
teil der luchs usaid ist es kostenlos
und verpasst keine videos mehr und ich
sehe halt gerade bei diesen tickets der
videos von mir mal das 70 die das hier
anschauen nicht abonnent von einem kanal
sind also ihr habt nichts und klickt auf
abonnieren das hat nicht geräumt ich bin
so ein
vereint komm ich gebe euch noch ein
letztes ding wieder danach kommt das
auto
[Musik]